Traduttore: Andrea Busetto
Revisore: Luisa Lualdi
Parliamo di accessori moda,
quindi borse, valigie, cinture,
ma anche calzature e gioielli.
Si tratta di categorie quotidiane,
afferenti al mondo del fashion
e del lifestyle.
Oggetti quotidiani
che siamo abituati a vedere,
a utilizzare molteplici volte
durante l’arco di una giornata,
fanno costantemente
parte della nostra vita
e rientrano nel nostro
scenario quotidiano.
Gli accessori sono senza dubbio
oggetti con una componente
estetica straordinaria,
spesso sono addirittura
l’elemento decisivo
nella definizione
dell’immagine di una persona.
La costruzione
del nostro aspetto è un’operazione
che mettiamo in atto in pratica tutti
i giorni in modo più o meno consapevole
e in questo processo
ogni oggetto indossabile,
quindi dall’abito all’accessorio
concorre a trasmettere
quello che vogliamo
comunicare di noi stessi.
Ma mentre l’abbigliamento
tende ad essere sempre più basico,
semplice, omologante,
è invece sempre più forte
il ruolo dell’accessorio
nell’esprimere la personalità, e quindi
nel definire l’identità
di chi lo indossa.
È quindi innegabile il ruolo
della componente estetica dell’accessorio,
come strumento di comunicazione del sé.
Ma spesso tendiamo a dimenticarci
che questa non è l’unica componente;
anzi, quella fondamentale è quella che
gli accessori sono anche e soprattutto
degli oggetti che hanno
delle funzioni pratiche, una o più di una.
Pensiamo alle spille,
che chiudono cardigan, cappotti,
oppure cinture che
sostengono i pantaloni, le gonne.
Le borse e le valigie addirittura sono
forse gli accessori
funzionali per eccellenza,
per definizione nascono proprio
con la funzione di contenere e trasportare
degli oggetti.
Nella preistoria erano i semi,
nell’antica Grecia le monete, e così via.
Anche nella contemporaneità gli accessori
sono oggetti che
costantemente instaurano
un rapporto funzionale,
con gli abiti e anche con altri oggetti,
per contenerli, per proteggerli,
per fermarli, per legarli al corpo,
quindi le valigie per trasportare
gli effetti personali,
le borse che si portano
insieme ad altre borse
o che si appoggiano sopra le valigie.
Quindi gli accessori
si interfacciano tra di loro
e si interfacciano
necessariamente con il corpo,
lo vestono, lo contengono,
vi si appoggiano, lo sostengono.
Per questo motivo l’utente
con la sua ergonomia, con le sue esigenze,
è centrale nella progettazione
di un accessorio.
E sui due universi,
dell’utente e delle sue necessità,
deve sempre di più vertere la ricerca,
la ricerca che è il punto di partenza
per progettare degli accessori
veramente funzionali.
Nel design la ricerca è fondamentale,
ai miei studenti
chiedo sempre di guardarsi intorno,
di identificare aspetti nei quali
i prodotti esistenti sono carenti,
e soprattutto di identificare
delle esigenze che
l’offerta che è attualmente sul mercato
non soddisfa ancora.
Per sapere per esempio
come sarà la borsa di domani
basta già oggi guardarsi intorno:
non troveremo chiaramente già
quella che è l’estetica
della borsa di domani,
ma sicuramente ne troveremo le funzioni.
Perché le funzioni della borsa di domani
sono le funzioni che le borse del presente
non sono in grado di svolgere.
Ed è proprio dalla ricerca,
dall’osservazione
che nascono le idee innovative.
Ne sanno qualcosa
le povere signore del mio quartiere
che, soprattutto quelle anziane,
tutte le volte mi colgono sul fatto
mentre le osservo quando si aggirano
con le loro borse per strada,
queste signore per lungo tempo
mi hanno scambiato per uno scippatore,
perché mi vedevano sempre
con gli occhi puntati sulle loro borse
quando le incrociavo per strada...
per fortuna poi hanno capito
che sono innocuo
e non avevo nessuna intenzione
di rubare le borse.
Quindi osservando però queste signore
ho raccolto molte informazioni preziose
per il mio lavoro,
perché è proprio la ricerca
delle abitudini quotidiane di un target
il primo passo del percorso progettuale;
indagando che cosa
le persone devono trasportare,
quale mezzo utilizzano per spostarsi,
come indossano le borse,
quante volte le aprono, come le chiudono,
quale mano utilizzano
per aprirle e chiuderle,
quindi studiando il consumatore
nel quotidiano
si individuano delle nuove esigenze.
E cercando di soddisfare queste esigenze
prendono avvio i progetti straordinari.
Ci sono infatti anche accessori
che esulano dal contesto del quotidiano,
sono degli accessori estremi,
i virtuosismi stilistici,
che sono straordinari per definizione
in quanto pensati
per delle occasioni speciali.
Per esempio i gioielli da indossare
alla prima della Scala,
le borse da red carpet
o le borse da sfilata.
In questi accessori
non c’è nulla di ordinario,
i materiali sono rari e preziosi,
le lavorazioni sono artigianali,
complesse, i volumi sono estremi.
Quindi borse e gioielli qui devono
rientrare perfettamente
in un’estetica che è
l’estetica della collezione,
dove accessori e abbigliamento
si completano a vicenda
per creare un total look
che dev’essere forte e coerente.
E quindi questa è
la dimensione della creatività pura,
qui i limiti legati ai costi di produzione
si dissolvono,
le dinamiche commerciali sono cancellate
da quelle che sono le esigenze d’immagine
e il prodotto quindi arriva
ad astrarsi dal quotidiano
fino a diventare
quello che è un sogno irraggiungibile.
Ma anche gli accessori straordinari
devono essere indossabili,
quindi per quanto limitati
a un’occasione d’uso speciale,
la funzionalità di questi prodotti
va progettata.
Quindi anche una borsa di sfilata,
in quanto borsa,
deve poter contenere
e trasportare qualcosa,
si deve poter portare comodamente,
si deve poter aprire e chiudere
facilmente e in modo sicuro.
Da designer quindi non considero corretto
il progetto della più bella
clutch da sfilata
nella quale però non si possa inserire
neanche un rossetto
o che sia così pesante
da non poter essere indossata comodamente
per 5 minuti consecutivi.
Bisogna infatti ricordarsi
quando si progetta un accessorio
che gli elementi estetici
e gli elementi funzionali
non sono antitetici,
quindi si tratta di due aspetti
che sono compatibili e che insieme
vanno a costruire
quello che è un buon progetto.
Il design è quindi straordinario
quando riesce a tradurre una funzione
in una forma gradevole
o riesce a rendere funzionali e pratici
degli oggetti che hanno un grande fascino
a livello estetico.
Tutto questo è relativamente facile
nell’alto di gamma
perché qui le lavorazioni sono
artigianali, i materiali sono pregiati
e tutto questo consente
in maniera relativamente semplice
di dar vita a dei prodotti straordinari.
Quello che però è ancora più affascinante
nel lavoro di un designer è la capacità
di calare questa straordinarietà
dell’accessorio nella realtà quotidiana,
quindi con un occhio a quella
che è l’industrializzazione del prodotto.
Infatti solo con l’innovazione
del processo produttivo
da parte del creativo si può garantire
un prodotto di qualità
a un prezzo accessibile ai più.
Credo infatti fermamente che il ruolo
del designer di moda si stia evolvendo:
i creativi sempre di più
si devono allontanare
da una visione autoriferita
e da un approccio
puramente estetico al prodotto.
Questo non basta più: nel futuro
il designer si focalizzerà
sempre di più sul ruolo funzionale
dell’abbigliamento e dell’accessorio,
con l’obiettivo di rispondere
a delle esigenze
espresse o latenti del consumatore.
Il prodotto quindi sarà progettato
dando sempre più rilevanza a quegli
aspetti di performance e di comfort
si dovrà ragionare sul valore generato
per il consumatore
in termini di funzioni assolte
oltre che di conferimento di status
o, come dicevamo prima, di definizione
delle identità attraverso l’estetica.
Quindi il buon progetto sarà sempre meno
valutato in base alla bellezza estetica,
all’armonia delle proporzioni,
verrà un po’ data per scontata
quella capacità di un designer
di generare degli oggetti belli.
La variabile invece che porterà
più vantaggio competitivo
a un prodotto rispetto ad un altro sarà
quella capacità progettata di gestire
delle situazioni problematiche
in modo innovativo.
Quindi la borsa più comoda e funzionale
per esempio per spostarsi in moto,
la valigia che più agevolmente
ci aiuta a superare
i controlli di sicurezza in aeroporto:
questi stanno diventando
i criteri cruciali
per la scelta di un prodotto
rispetto a un altro
da parte di un consumatore,
quindi per questo si sta
accentuando sempre di più
all’interno delle organizzazioni
il ruolo strategico del design,
che diventerà proprio un elemento
fondante delle strategie aziendali,
con l’obiettivo principale
di generare innovazione
e differenziarsi dai competitor.
Tutto questo non solo nell’ambito
dell’abbigliamento e dell’accessorio,
ma soprattutto in altri settori:
dall’automotive al food.
In generale si sente quindi sempre di più
l’esigenza di un approccio creativo
che sia incentrato
sugli obiettivi aziendali da un lato
e sulle esigenze del consumatore
dall’altro;
quindi sarà l’incontro
tra il bello ed il funzionale,
l’accattivante e l’innovativo,
a generare valore,
quindi la bellezza salverà il mondo ma
solo se i designer riusciranno a innovare
il processo produttivo
e a interpretare le esigenze delle persone
con lo scopo di migliorarne
la vita quotidiana
attraverso dei prodotti ben progettati.
E la qualità e il valore viaggeranno
indipendentemente
dal posizionamento prezzo.
Il progetto straordinario quindi non è
il costosissimo virtuosismo da sfilata
ma è l’accessorio performante
che riesce meglio
a eliminare un disagio
o a generare comfort.
Straordinaria è infatti
quell’idea innovativa
che riesce a rendere
migliore il quotidiano.
Grazie.